this is a chance to write your own story
to find a better life for you and your
friends
come on what have you got to lose the
bad guys is sure to be a tailwagger this
quirky tarantino for kids is jam-packed
with a-list voice actors and we're going
into the booth to see how they brought
these characters to life let's do this
number one let's take a look at the gang
we don't have five minutes the curtain's
going up any minute sometimes voice
actors don't get the luxury of working
with their scene partners due to
location issues timing or these days
even coveted but that doesn't seem to be
the case for the bad guys they got to
work as a team this is gonna taste extra
sweet cause i know how bad you want it
and by the looks of it the actors were a
significantly less toxic team than the
bad guys they voiced i want you to
smack it
stab it saute think to it sacrifice it
oh shave it shaving the cat is
definitely the answer
save it i want you to set in the top so
obviously i want you to save it right
yeah in retrospect that's obvious even
from the initial table read the acting
was on point everybody really brings in
their personality to the characters and
really shapes him number two they call
him the big bad wolf but he doesn't seem
so scary to us
lately sam rockwell's been getting into
more voice acting work he's played both
sides too taking on roles as heroes and
complex characters who's up for another
job
a big one he played the titular
character in the one and only ivan why
do they want an angry gorilla anyway and
he also played hickory a yodeling troll
in disguise in trolls world tour it was
the only way to save her beautiful your
thing but let's get back to mr wolfe did
you try rebooting sam has worked with a
lot of the cast before i worked with
zazi and mark a lot a little bit with
aquafina hollywood is a pretty tight
circle to break into that's for sure
nice work now let's make like a wolf and
get the pack out of here fun fact this
isn't sam rockwell's first voice job
involving guinea pigs well that just got
weird he played the guinea pig team
leader named darwin in g-force back in
2009. suck in your gut this time around
he's playing the predator not the prey
uh superhero in a tiny package in the
bad guys that role goes to number three
the best human being on the planet you
got that right richard iowa is playing
professor marmalade oh goody he got into
voice acting within the last decade but
he's had some pretty great roles and
he's fantastic at voice acting too
they say experience is the best teacher
his first voice role was in trolls no
wait it was a different troll movie the
box trolls huh what are the odds if you
don't recognize him from the list of
awesome live-action shows he's done
perhaps you'll recognize him as jerry
from seoul oh we guess that isn't very
helpful either
everybody's named jerry well perhaps you
know about the show apple and onion i
don't know and i don't think i want to
know quick let's hide he's pretty
versatile stop
for goodness sake okay fine we'll go bug
number four miss tarantula guys calm
down i'm on it this time around aquafina
is taking on a tarantula it's crime time
baby she's done the voices of plenty of
animals including a couple birds like
quail from storks and scuttle from the
up-and-coming live-action the little
mermaid she has also taken on the bird's
natural prey the villainous pig in the
second angry birds movie terrifying wow
most notably she played the dragon sisu
in raya and the last dragon impressed
huh aquafina is more than happy to play
the creepy crawler it's fun to play a
character that like knows
what she's doing at all times a true
rarity to know what's going on in life i
want to channel someone who was really
good at what they did and had total
control over that her favorite part of
playing miss tarantula was the panic
attacks because the character gets all
puffed up so to record she would put her
arm over her mouth and talk in her
muffled sound but there's nothing
muffled about this next character number
five mr shark i'm having a baby is that
a doctor or perhaps several security
guards who can leave that post and help
me it was a collaborative process
between the director and craig to find
the voices do i get to improvise no the
only improvisation was in the way he
spoke the lines but the lines themselves
did not change you may recognize his
voice as cookie the ogre from shrek
forever after wait what's this that's my
chimichanga state or perhaps as kevin
and doolittle
revenge we are particularly looking
forward to seeing what he's done with mr
shark oh stop you're making me blush all
right moving on to
number six mr snake mark maron has been
a voice actor on a bunch of different tv
shows for an episode or two coming up is
the movie dc league of super pets for
which he voiced super villain lex luthor
well well well
if it isn't the justice league odds are
lex and mr snake don't sound too
different from each other i can do
voices but none of them are that
different than me to get the performance
right for snake they had to work on the
bond between him and wolf so mark and
sam did a lot of one-on-one work to
really nail that dynamic we don't have
five minutes next up number seven mr
piranha let's do this this is the second
time sam rockwell and anthony ramos have
worked on a film together as you may
recall anthony played king trollix in
trolls world tour no way i forgot he was
in trolls that's right that's that's
awesome
surprise it wasn't until very late in
the process that mr piranha was given
the song good tonight and we'll be
adding it to our playlist they were like
yo like we think he should sing in this
gallery scene anthony had a lot of fun
with this role trying to decide on the
right voice for the character you know i
did this like kind of gravely thing with
his voice keeping that voice up in the
studio every day must have been painful
well he isn't the only one left
speechless by his performance ah
wordplay
i don't get it ugh never mind number
eight diane foxington and now the moment
we've all been waiting for this isn't
zossy bates first voice acting role yeah
well
that ship's already sailed the first was
a donut-shaped cat in extinct we're
pretty delicious we want to know whose
idea this was
they say that art reveals more about the
viewer than the artist mr
saucy loved the freedom that voice
acting allowed her not having to worry
about micro movements on camera her
eyebrows were free to jump around i mean
it was a mess and she could you know
just be big are you still with us we've
got a couple more characters to cover as
if those poor rodents haven't been
through enough already next up number
nine tiffany fluff it disney flevit
channel 6 action news the bad guys have
struck again before playing tiffany lily
singh played a mini corn in ice age
collision course actually she played two
of them misty and bubbles this guy for
real whatever
lily loves her character in the bad guys
because she feels they share a lot of
the same expressions so my facial
expressions are very what's the word i'm
looking for a lot you know who else is a
lot number 10 misty loggins
a crime's a crime and you are guilty
recognize alex's voice please tell me
you didn't forget i like in general
playing no-nonsense characters
especially women who know what they want
and go after it with a fierce passion
she finds that the police chief does
that very well case closed she's not
always successful which alex also likes
she enjoys being a bit of a fool so she
was attracted to the layers in the
character this was all an elaborate plot
to catch the bad guys
we left the most prolific voice actor
until the end oops sorry alex so it
doesn't seem like any of the actors had
to push too far out of their comfort
zone to make this movie happen except
for maybe craig but either way it seems
like the bad guys was a blast to record
if you could have played any of the
characters in the movie who would you
choose let us know in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things